in a lot of the behind the scenes shots
from Avatar the way of water you'll see
these monitors zoom in and you'll see
the performance of the actor playing
courage a nine foot tall Navi the
robotic monitor was a reference for the
actor in the scene and for the VFX team
who added the CG Giant in post it was a
huge step forward from the first avatar
which only had a handful of scenes with
humans and Navi interacting compared to
the sequel filmmakers have been making
actors taller or smaller than they
really are for over a century but making
sure the scale is realistic without
ruining the illusion is where the real
work begins and one of the Pioneers in
the space is WETA the visual effects
company that's overseen some of the most
groundbreaking CG characters of all
sizes in movies like The Lord of the
Rings and The Way of water we always
have to play games in film to make that
feel and actually be able to get good
performances from the different scale
that you want say six foot the tree is
going to need to be 30 smaller if the
characters are going to be 30 bigger so
there's a lot of planning involved there
it's a puzzle filmmakers have been
trying to solve since the invention of
film take this shot of 1909's Princess
nicotine the tiny fairy next to this
normal-sized human was actually standing
on a platform far behind the table this
is known as forced perspective in which
one performer in frame will place
themselves closer to the camera and the
other farther away Force perspective
requires a sharp depth of field so both
the foreground and background appear
equally in focus and that means a lot of
light visual FX artist Peter ellenshaw
said that when working on 1959's Darby
O'Gill and the little people the
production used so many lights for the
force perspective shots that it blew out
the circuit breakers at a nearby power
station
forced perspective works when the
characters are separated when they have
to interact things get more complicated
this was an issue Peter Jackson
encountered when he started shooting the
Lord of the Rings The Fellowship of the
Ring with Wizards dwarves and Hobbits to
expand how scale could be used in these
movies The Crew had to manipulate their
sets and props while filming at just the
right angle here you can see Gandalf and
Frodo sitting side by side alright then
keep your secrets but on set Elijah Wood
was sitting on a shorter stool pushed
farther back while Ian McAllen sat right
in front of the camera these sorts of
raised sets are a common force
perspective technique that you can also
see two years later in elf and force
perspective also needs to be paired with
props that are made to scale in this
shot Frodo and Gandalf were actually
sitting at a table that had been split
apart on one side where normal sized
props for Frodo and for Gandalf a small
scale table with a mug that was
two-thirds the size the the reason these
forced perspective shots work is that
the camera stays still most of the
camera moves were quite locked off once
the camera moves the illusion is ruined
it's screwed with your head a little bit
when you're on set because when you
watched it from the side it didn't look
right at all
to accomplish this moving forced
perspective shot the crew placed the
table on a moving platform and
programmed the camera to move in the
opposite direction they programmed the
camera's moves in advance making them
easy to replicate that way in scenes
like this one they could shoot the
actors separately in the exact same way
and seamlessly combine them the shorter
Bilbo could walk in front of the much
taller Gandalf and it could all be
combined with the two versions of
Bilbo's house one hobbit-sized and one
made 33 percent smaller for Gandalf
and these shots could consist of more
than two characters at once
to get all four Hobbits two humans a
dwarf an elf and a wizard into the same
shot the crew filmed Scaled Composites
of each actor against a blue screen with
the proper Framing and camera angle for
the character's Heights the images were
then composited together this technology
continued to be perfected and used to
expand the Lord of the Rings universe
but it hit a snag as wetta worked on
Avatar and The Hobbit an Unexpected
Journey two movies shot in 3D a lot of
the cheats we were able to get away with
before we can't get away with as much
now so instead of shooting with one
camera you're shooting with side-by-side
cameras so you get proper 3D the false
perspective really falls apart quite
quickly because you understand the depth
of the shots the motion control really
kicked into gear for The Hobbit trilogy
at this point the cameras were much more
precise and reliable than they were in
the original trilogy like during this
sequence it got the results you needed
you were able to do camera moves you
wanted you were able to move around do
the different things you had to do to
get the shots but it can pose a
challenge when the actors are playing
non-cg characters because the actors
were frequently shot in different takes
to account for the differing Heights
they weren't able to directly interact
with one another it wasn't very actor
friendly size manipulation is a lot
easier if the character is fully CG like
the Giant in The BFG played by Mark
rylance Mark could be on set with actor
Ruby Barnhill as long as he acted above
her on this platform but even this movie
innovated new riffs on past techniques
for example Ruby was surrounded by
oversized props when her character was
in the Giant's house but unlike past
large-scale props some of them were blue
that way the animators could add
movements to this giant-sized squash
some other tricks to maintain proper eye
line and sense of scale are low-tech but
effective in The Avengers films Josh
Brolin plays the eight foot tall Thanos
the mocap sensors he wore were so good
at picking up subtle expressions and
movements that his real height didn't
matter until he was interacting directly
with other characters so to fill out the
height Gap in this shot Josh wore a
cutout on top of his head so Robert
Downey Jr knew exactly where to look you
can also see the 5-4 Tatiana maslani
wearing a cut out here to look like
she's the 6'7 She-Hulk just like in The
BFG she stood on an elevated platform in
these shots and occasionally sat on a
cushion but eyeline isn't the only issue
you need to resolve when making a
performer taller in this walking shot
She-Hulk isn't standing next to anybody
but wetta found another issue Tatiana's
real stride didn't match up with
she-hulk's much longer legs where
Tatiana would take 10 steps She-Hulk
would take seven that's where
retargeting or character mapping comes
in this is when the VFX artists take all
the movements and expressions from the
performance capture cameras and apply
them to the animated character when the
character is a different size where does
software Nuance needs to fill in the
gaps like in translating actor Sam
worthington's posture over his Navi body
and Avatar or turning Andy's circus into
Caesar in the Planet of the Apes trilogy
if he's quadrupedal you want to make
sure that what is absolute here from his
performance is his two feet and the
markers on the end of the arm extension
the crew worked with actor Malia Araya
to retarget she-hulk's stride Malia
could serve as a more height appropriate
stand-in but this isn't a new practice
in the past stand-ins were used in shots
where you couldn't see their face by
having Malia's movements recorded on a
mocap stage VFX artists could map her
stride along with Tatiana's facial
capture onto She-Hulk everything about
you is just working thank you the better
CG and Camera Tech has gotten the more
seamless these scale shots can be for
all of the technological breakthroughs
in the original Avatar there are
actually very few shots of humans and
Navi characters together as the process
at the time was much less precise take
it easy don't get ahead of yourself for
instance the shot of natiri holding Jake
Sully's human body was achieved by two
green suit performers approximating Navi
size but that new eye line system meant
there could be many more shots of humans
and Navi together it consisted of a
monitor playing an actor's previously
recorded performance that monitor was
attached to overhead cables at Four
Points so whenever scoresby had a scene
with Courage the monitor would play back
Stephen Lang's performance at the proper
height it got rotations it got height so
as he moved around it knew exactly where
his head was supposed to be his eyes
were supposed to be and it moved around
set take this shot where porridge walks
alongside two human-sized characters we
had a live-action character Kevin Dorman
actually walking beside Kevin Dorman is
the easy one right he's just live action
character walking on a construction set
but he has to match the speed of slang
which was performance capture so we take
the performance capture and we put it on
the cable cam the eye line system and we
actually ran that down the construction
set and Kevin Dorman was able to walk
along with him and he had an eye line so
he knew the speed he was supposed to
walk but it wasn't just the actors who
needed precise references real-time
depth compositing allowed James Cameron
to see the CG performances as the
footage was being captured by seeing a
rough version of what the finalized CG
shot would look like the director could
better set up shots of CG and
live-action characters without worrying
about a single camera move ruining the
illusion witta also used real-time
compositing on the first avatar but the
traditional combining of CG and live
action footage is typically done in
layers back in the day you sort of had
an A over B which meant you had either
the live action or the CG and it was one
over the other the new system built for
the way of water looked at each shot's
elements in pixels instead of layers we
wanted to place the depth of each pixel
as we were shooting so that instead of
doing A over B we could take each point
on space and say you're either in front
or behind the other character and that
helps achieve the correct scale you
could
you could how big someone was because
otherwise you're just getting that fake
perspective even inadvertently because a
character is always over the top of one
another thanks to all of weta's
Innovations making a character look
bigger or smaller is no longer a
guessing game those perspectives can be
less forced but even in the completely
CG Pandora some of the most convincing
scale Illusions are tangible like when
quartz holds up his own human-sized
skull on set there was an actual prop
skull but scaled down from human size
that way the actor's hand looked Navi
sized when he crushes it it feels like a
normal size skull because you never
think about his hand being a small
normal size hand you just assume it's
the Navy's hand crushing it because you
go from a shot of slang to a hand and
your brain just fills it in as just a
big hand instead of a painted smaller
hand
thank you